today we're going to show you a demo of
oxides new 3d engine nitrous this 3d
benchmark called star swarm is running
on AMD's new mantel API
AMD's mantle api is particularly well
suited for nitrous because it supports a
high degree of parallelism
what makes nitrous special is that if
it's truly core neutral every CPU core
talks to the GPU nitrous already has
three games in active development using
the engine and a demo of this will soon
be available to download from Steam so
you can see it for yourself
nitrous delivers bleeding edge
performance on DirectX as well but to
maintain the frame rate we have to back
off on some high-end graphics options
like motion blur multi samples with
motion blur disabled our performance
increases dramatically each of those
ships is prioritizing threats and
battling according to its AI every laser
blast and missile is an independent
physics object nitrous opens new doors
for game designers with these kinds of
capabilities with motion blur back on
star swarm drops significantly but it
gives you a preview of the kinds of
movie effects we will soon see in games
because nitrous has been designed from
the ground up to take advantage of the
multi-core CPUs game designers can
envision new types of games that simply
weren't possible before one of the
secrets behind nitrous is its
implementation of object space rendering
the same general technique high-end
movie CGI effects studios use except
nitrous can render it in a game in real
time we didn't want to sacrifice detail
in fidelity to chase a unit count though
nitrous can render little details as
well as big scenes check out the capital
ships turrets note that each ship has
turrets that track independently the
hyper efficient use of the CPU and the
nitrous engine frees up processing power
to be spent on other
play features for example we now have
enough cpu to simulate gravity
individual / ship turrets muzzle flashes
and more these little touches lended
intangible realism to any game imagine
them playing out on the truly massive
scale that nitrous enables nitrous opens
doors for game designers to explore new
experiences that aren't possible using
earlier technology the scope a nitrous
powered game can achieve is only the
beginning of the next generation of
strategy games and we can't wait to see
what talented game designers do with our
engine